any dating and happening are you single
with the deal hey Maddie we know you're
a busy girl and all but we'd love for
you to update us on your relationship
status
everyone was gushing when they found out
that you and Stevie Wonder's son were
allegedly dating but now it looks like
you've moved on to someone new
we're dying to know why you and Kyle and
Morris didn't work out you guys made
such an adorable couple but hey we're
happy as long as you're happy Maddie
Ziegler is one of the most famous
teenagers in America she's talented kind
and super pretty it would appear that
Maddie recently split up with her
boyfriend
Thailand and it looks like she moved on
to someone else keep watching to find
out who Maddie is currently dating it
was a confront I would kiss him Jack
Kelly at one point in time Maddie
Ziegler and Jack Kelly were all that her
fans could talk about they redeemed the
cutest couple ever thanks to all the
adorable pictures they used to post on
social media but one day the picture
stopped coming and Maddie and Jack
announced their split Jack and Maddie
dated for about a year and a half and
they seemed super happy they started
dating in January 2017 when they were
both just 15 years old but there was
trouble in paradise and it had to do
with the fact that they lived worlds
apart Jack Kelly lived in Australia
whereas Maddie lived in Los Angeles
which made keeping in touch a full-time
commitment I think I'm going to be in
Australia with him so yeah there goes
according to confidential Maddie and
Jack were just taking a break and the
decision was mutual but after a little
while things got ugly between the once
happy couple Maddie unfollowed jack on
Instagram
leading him to post good riddance with a
black heart on his Instagram bio this
shady Act made it easier for fans to
stop shipping Jack and Maddie Jack was
Maddie's first official boyfriend but
believe it or not Jack wasn't Maddie's
first kiss
Gino cosculluela Gino cosculluela is
rumored to have been Maddie Ziggler's
first kiss
unfortunately for Gino his dancing
career sort of hit a wall after kissing
Maddie on the set of Dance Moms fans
were rooting for Gino and Maddie's to go
steady but whether or not they ever
officially dated is up for debate Maddie
and Gino met when they were dancing for
candy apples Dance Center
however Gino once danced for the Abby
Lee dance
alongside Maddy in 2014 in season four
Maddie and Gino were given the duets
this girl's got to be kissed and well
Abby Lee Miller pretty much forced them
to share a kiss at the end of the dance
Maddie described the kiss as disgusting
it was a Quran I would kiss him but not
to him and Gino took this to heart he
fired back by calling her ugly and
disgusting which ultimately put an end
to their relationship
kenneth san jose back when Maddie
Ziegler was 13 years old she and dancer
kenneth san jose became very close very
quickly but despite fans being eager for
them to make things official that day
never came both maddie and kenneth are
super secretive people who like to keep
their love life top secret however
Maddie's younger sister Mackenzie once
asked to them by accident on social
media the incident happened when Maddie
posted a picture of her in kenneth
maddie commented on how much she missed
Kenan and Kenzie commented that she
approved them dating however Maddie
never acknowledged the comments making
fans all the more curious Kenneth and
Maddie met on set of Dance Moms and 2016
[Music]
Maddie and Kenneth would have made the
cutest couple of all time but obviously
something went wrong because their
romance ended as quickly as it began
Thailand Morris Maddie Ziegler doesn't
like to dish about who she's dating and
we don't really blame her being in the
public eye has turned Maddie into a
master evader Maddie has been asked
about her relationship with Kyle and
Morris for over a year now but she has
yet to admit that they're dating but
we're not buying it according to people
Maddie and Kyle ins met backstage on
Dancing with the Stars juniors their
paths cross because Maddie's sister
Mackenzie and Mandla were both competing
on the show Maddie and Kyle ins have
posted plenty of pictures together and
their body language says it all and
while many of us believe that Maddie and
Kyle ins were going strong it appears as
though the couple has put an end to
their top secret romance Thailand
celebrated his 18th birthday on
September 1st 2019 but Maddie was
nowhere to be found
she didn't wish him a happy birthday on
Instagram and they didn't appear to be
celebrating together so has Maddie moved
on to someone else well it sure looks
like it
Eddie Benjamin Maddy isn't when to post
Instagram pictures with boys so whenever
she does fans automatically raise an
eyebrow in August of 2019 Maddy posted a
picture of herself
Eddie Benjamin and an adorable pup but
now fans are wondering if these two are
dating since pictures of Kyle and Morris
haven't surfaced in weeks Eddie is an
Australian singer-songwriter and bassist
and we all know that Maddie has a thing
for the boys Down Under
but unlike Jack Kelly Eddie is based in
both Sydney Australia and Los Angeles
and so long-distance dating won't be an
issue what do you guys think are Maddie
and Eddie dating and would you ship them
if they were sound off in the comments
below hit that subscribe button so you
never miss another video and don't
forget to give this one a big thumbs up
thanks for watching the things we'll see
you next time
[Music]